hello and welcome video clintus musta
got bad shook with that you're done even
off okay yeah what did I go Knight f6 in
the first place okay okay i can try a
king's indian for a change wasn't really
intended sure okay III whoa okay III
that's unexpected
very early crease I play interesting
okay now i can take and get the Queen to
a 10 k z6 is an option and trying to
take 9 a-6 also possible please let's go
see six just intending to take trees the
Pont then freeze is wrong with Lexi's
make sure c5 is not happening it's got
nice 25 and stuff like that but I'm sure
how dangerous this really is night a six
I don't know if this is an idea no it's
difficult to say let's play it
the idea sometimes to play c5 in such a
position but usually not if if yeah and
this could be completely wrong but I'm
trying keeping this closed takes Knight
eggs should be okay I hope no I'm not
doing it okay it is not threatening to
take their age 65 is extremely slow I
guess I have to and probably not a good
King Daniel K yet b6 as possible this is
sorry not such a big problem
ok IM sorry my voice is completely off
take stakes loopy am yeah maybe queen 27
holes but that's not fun
yeah but does he have something better
than taking now this one he's have okay
I'm Bishop d7 just to check I think too
i miss something here it's possible that
that sometimes they have southern Texas
this position is not X not very well
coordinated ready
[Music]
yeah but without looks you know this
should be somewhat okay so this is
always safely protected I mean okay i'm
not going to checkmate them that much as
we gathered it's a very okay ending yeah
I don't know 233 on going to do this
stuff to activate the bishop I can't
Roger go around their time yeah 93
Bishop a forces idea I understand maybe
I should actually take I should have
brought this around on the other side
not allowing this trade it would have
been better really
you
is he really winning these six I don't
see how if there's some idea there how
he might win this pond where are you
going time morning where are you going
with all this okay
by using your body I don't see it I
don't see it I know it takes can you
take that twice from at five and take it
from there five
so am i threatening 964 now of course I
do I was threatening anyway and he goes
97 okay to bring the ship around we
should be five will be pretty good ok
check check okay white resides Jeff that
was probably bad at some point I mean
not a bit lots of style their name but
bit later yeah I'm not the greatest
Kings Indian player ever only this one I
mean I think I'm pretty ok up to hear it
that night a 65 sign probably was rotten
the engine wants to take and hide 45 and
this is the this is the thing I can do
or this one this is and fight for fight
for the center which is probably the
right way to do when I it's probably
quite ok yeah this is whole ideas from
the rubbish
and please disc and why this was always
better now this had looked really really
really annoying I was quite lucky
actually then it isn't worse and I mean
the advantage that the engine gives is
still kind of manageable and
disadvantaged I mean and yeah and this
is this is true this ending it should be
good for black I just have more space
here and now I probably play it wrong
somehow after you got the bishop traded
I mean I don't see anything for me and I
think I'm not worth also I don't think I
am I mean it couldn't be completely sure
what I think this should be equal oh
that's a great movie wow wow that's a
great move hahahaha yeah well he came up
to it you cannot take this because now
I'm rescuing my night with check and if
he takes I play here Wow and now he has
all carries pieces are completely
misplaced that if he takes the f3 this
is made already this and g2g one made
why I would have been a chakra if
someone plays this again so you know
you're up against some kind of genius or
computer except that oh my what a shot
okay I did not see that one I can still
take this time to threatening f3
I mean this is something in a tournament
game in a long time control game that's
something that you can find but in a
bridge game now I was always thinking I
should have countered play with the
sacrificial ideas oh here you can take a
completely overlook that yeah so I can
take now empty be missed at okay we can
still move the King which isn't that
clear not an easy is not easy no what's
from okay i would put a big step of the
bit lucky this this win i mean i had to
had chances but tough very tough to
sports or sacrifice sale ok guys thanks
for watching